aujourd'hui le meilleur allié de marine
le pen cemac ronces et les gilets jaunes
c'est la politique que mène mâcon depuis
quelques années peut-être que le système
choisira une autre alternative en 2017
en 2016
il y avait un sondage qui donnait qui a
donné marine le pen gagnante face à
françois hollande
françois hollande s'est mis en retrait
et peut-être macron se mettrait en
retrait louhans venu si sondage après
sondage les français plébiscitent un
vote
un vote est reine à votre marine le pen
il ya des raisons objectives sont sont
lourdes me semble-t-il les idées du
front national sont majoritaires en
france il ya une enquête qui est menée
chaque année depuis 30 ans par kantar
tns sofres le monde sur la perception
des idées du front national à deux tiers
c'est devenir un feuilleton deux tiers
des français plébiscitent en tout cas
dans les domaines régaliens immigration
sécurité frontières les idées du front
national mais aux deux tiers il rejette
le marine le pen et hier jean-marie le
pen autrement dit ils plébiscitent le
message et ils récusent le médium de
termes électoraux il ya aujourd'hui à
deux blocs
quelle est l'alternative entre macron et
le pen ya l'espace politique se réduit
ces deux forces politiques aspirant le
la puissance gravitationnelle de ces
deux mouvements aspire autour de lui ses
marges donc les as l'air et le centre
droit pour macron le centre les
conservateurs pour marine le pen
mélenchon n'a plus du tout l'espace
politique en 2017 il y avait deux
offrent un peu plus distant c'est
important d'être au goût bliss a
vraiment égal en termes électoraux 20%
mélenchon ou 20% marine le pen mélenchon
a disparu des écrans radar il n'est plus
populiste ans aujourd'hui la réactiver
de la gauche de la gauche il et
indigéniste des colonials postféministe
courir tout ce qu'on voudra mais il
n'est plus populiste en 2017 mac
mélenchon était populiste donc il y
avait deux offres complice aujourd'hui
n'y a plus qu'une seule offre populiste
ce qui fait qu'ils risquent d'avoir un
très gros report de voix des
mélenchoniens en tout cas les catégories
populaires celles qui votent françois
ruffin et autres vers marine le pen oui
tout ça me fait dire que la donne a
changé et je prends pas conre produira
deux fois les mêmes erreurs
moi je pense aux débats de mitterrand 74
qui est dévastateur en 80 il démolit
démoli giscard le
l'homme du passé démoli l'homme du
passif
[Musique]